Super food dazu zählen beispielsweise acai beeren shazam weizengras und quinoa diese produkte gelten längst nicht mehr als reine
nahrungsmittel sondern als lifestyle produkte denn sie machen schlank und schön schützen vor krebs und geben den extra energieschub
Wenn ja wenn man der werbung glauben mag doch stecken tatsächlich superkräfte in diesen nahrungsmitteln oder wird das resumee
Am ende des videos vernichtend sein ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle facts bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Thema gibt es am ende des videos
den link sowie zepter könnt darauf klicken dann könnte ja auch themen vorschlagen die hier ziemlich schnell umgesetzt werden
Die acai beere kommt aus südamerika und ist viel mehr als eine unter vielen wehren denn sie macht schlank beugt wegen, ihrer
antioxidantien falten vor und gibt einen extra energieschub vor dem sport am besten
kombiniert man sie mit shazam echte alleskönner
schon die mayas wussten vor 5000 jahren dass sie aufgrund ihrer gesunden omega 3 und omega 6
fettsäuren besonders gesund sind auch die avocado die gut für das immunsystem die haare und die haut sein soll
Gehört in dieselbe reihe und ich könnte ewig weitermachen aber ihr merkt es selbst das hat alles eher
Wenig mit wissenschaft zu tun dafür sehr viel mit werbung und geldmacherei doch fest steht
mittlerweile hat das so genannte super food nicht nur die biomärkte und reformhäuser gestürmt bitter weil er kann man ja sagen und
alles andere auch, im discounter bekommen und noch mehr gefühl jedes zweite produkt
Sei, es ein gewöhnlicher müsliriegel oder eine tüte saft ist mit dem begriff
Superfit gelabelt und ja es stimmt das wird viel zu oft als werbezwecke missbraucht was ist wirklich dran an diesem star
lebensmitteln fest steht jetzt schon einmal super food ist meistens extrem teuer
Und da es sich meist um exotische lebensmittel handelt sind auch die weiten transportwege nach deutschland ökologisch gesehen
Eine echte vollkatastrophe mit nachhaltigkeit hat das nicht. Im geringsten
Zu tun ja wie wird super fit wenn eigentlich definiert es handelt sich um
nahrungsmittel achtung zitat die größere mengen an vitaminen mineralstoffen
protein
sekundären pflanzenstoffen und essentiellen fettsäuren
Enthalten das schreibt die ärzte zeitung und der medizinerin mediziner wird super und allerdings eher
Kritisch gesehen und das hat folgende gründe oft gibt es keine vorgaben bezüglich der hygiene bei der lagerung in den herkunftsländern
zudem kann superfit wechselwirkungen mit anderen medikamenten
haben goji beeren beispielsweise verstärkten
Blutverdünner bezüglich kia samt wird empfohlen nicht mehr als 15 gramm pro tag zu essen denn es ist erst seit kurzem
als neuartiges lebensmittel in der eu
Zugelassen zu leben haben tests wie beispielsweise der zeitschrift öko test ergeben dass viele super woods mit
schadstoffen belastet sind allen voran schimmel oder pestizide und das auch bei den getesteten produkten in
Bioqualität aber was sagen studien zu dem so oft postulierten
gesundheitsfördernden effekt es gibt tatsächlich
untersuchung die bestimmten superfit kandidaten positive effekte zu schreiben demnach können china sahen bei der
gewichtsreduktion helfen da sie einen appetit zügeln effekt mit sich bringen können dies hatte eine studie allerdings mit nur
77 übergewichtigen typ 2 diabetikern gezeigt eindeutige effekte auf kardiovaskuläre
risikofaktoren wie zb hohen blutdruck ergaben die hier sagen dagegen nicht spannend dagegen ist der vergleich mit
leinsamen wenn man nach studien geht denn diese samen bremsen steigenden blutzucker in ähnlich hohem maße wie fasan und
genau das empfehlen viele expertinnen und experten
heimische produkte wie eben leinsamen oder haferflocken
solchen super co2 azzam oder kino vorziehen denn schaut man sich die jeweiligen
Mikronährstoffe an dann sieht man dass es keine großen unterschiede zwischen super foods und heimischen produkten gibt auch in nüssen
pflanzenöle neben leinsamen sind omega 3 fettsäuren enthalten wie eben auch in der in den teuren sparsam nicht nur die acai beere
sondern auch in den meisten blauen und violetten früchten und gemüse arten finden sich
antioxidativ wirkende inhaltsstoffe heißt also mindestens genau
So gesund wie avocado und alle weiteren
gemüt arten und früchte sind brokkoli aubergine grünkohl rote beete heimische champignons heidelbeeren oder
schwarze johannisbeeren expertin experten schreiben vor allem brokkoli aufgrund seiner
antioxidativen wirkung krebs präventive eigenschaften, zu also
krebsvorsorge eigenschaften und da gesunde menschen in deutschland nicht mit vitaminmangel
zu kämpfen haben meinen medizinerinnen und mediziner das normale ernährung völlig ausreicht mehr noch super fit sei überflüssig auf der anderen seite
schadet sporadisch verzerrte superfit sicherlich nicht aber viel wichtiger es ist auch kein ersatz für eine ausgewogene ernährung dazu die
verbraucherzentrale hamburg zwar spielt die ernährung eine wichtige rolle für gesundheit und wohlbefinden doch positive wirkungen hängen nicht von einzelnen
speziellen lebensmitteln ab die auswertung einer großen zahl langfristig angelegte ernährungsstudie zeigt vielmehr dass nur eine insgesamt
gesundheitsorientierte ernährungsweise positive effekte zeigt
Hiermit erkläre ich also zum überflüssigsten produkt des monats
Das super gut wenn er als erstes neues zum thema ernährung
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
vorab garantiert der können dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
generelles der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das womit
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Bauernhöfe ohne tiere vegane landwirtschaft der zukunft an sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran